see that that was our pressure cooker  that was our forcing function  it was our forcing function to recognize  the nature of infinite oneness of  infinite consciousness of god  that is a formless indescribable quality  of the power to know that we habitually  overlook because we fixate  uncontrollably on attributes  on appearances  and so the individual undergoes  a process of decentralizing  themselves  from all of that  subconscious conditioning by radically  loving and accepting it  it dissolves and the individual  transcends it  and in doing so it unites  with god  god being the decentralized  force that is the universe  itself